first and foremost we have Mohsen Namjoo
who doesn't really need an introduction
he's an Iranian artist songwriter singer
music scholar and sitar player based in
Brooklyn New York he was hailed I'm not
sure whether he likes being called up
but he was hailed as the Bob Dylan of
Iran by the New York Times more than I
think about a decade ago actually he's a
visionary artist who blends the
classical Persian sitar with electric
guitar and rock and blues vocal
techniques with Persian Avaz since his
arrival to the u.s. in 2011
Namjoo has been touring the world to
sold-out concerts at prestigious halls
such as Palace of Fine Arts San
Francisco Conservatory Oh Sal 'verily
Milan Italy Disney Hall Los Angeles and
many more his latest album voices from
the east with Netherlands Blazers on
song was released in June 2017
Mawson will be in conversation with two
of his contemporaries Salma katha lady
the trombone player of the band Saturday
still has 127 Saturday still half was
what we would now call an underground
rock band in the 2000s of Iran very well
known and they worked together as a band
between 2002 and 2009 produced several
albums they still are together as a band
and the original members of the band and
are currently working on a new album
he's currently a music producer has been
for a while also in Brooklyn and runs
his own company called magnetic pink
whom an hamid ani who will function as
the interviewer between these two
musicians is himself also a musician he
was the lead singer of gap ash a band
that made music in the latter part of
the 2000s and who man has stopped sort
of making music consistently he's
currently a scientist as we said
yesterday he's a scientist at a pen and
and works on on the lungs lung diseases
he will be speaking to more sin and
Mack about the underground rock music
scene in the 2000s but before we start
that conversation and before I ask our
panelists to take to the stage I'm just
going to play two short clips to give
you a sense for what their music
sessions look like in the 2000s of Iran
first I'm going to play a short clip
from a practice session that mr. Namjoo
had with a band that he had together
with Abdi baiaram on fara and other
musician this session was recorded the
main part of their activity initially
was in Mashhad and so this and they
actually gave a series of concerts in
Mashhad some of which are still sort of
little gems that you can find on youtube
if you search really hard
this session is from 2001 it is from a
song that is called Nagasaki the dogs
woof woof and is sort of I think the
command this sort of the the
conversation about the song will come up
in between the musicians here's I'm just
playing a short excerpt of this practice
session it's not very good video in part
because it's from 2001 so this is 17
years ago at this point
[Music]
in a moment you will see most I'm not
doing the next half corner of the screen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoops okay and it was a bit of a abrupt
but it was the video was coming to an
end and here is a practice session of
the Bands that we still have 127 in a
sort of makeshift studio they had called
the goal Hoonah the green house and I
think over the years a lot of musicians
in that scene and a lot of sort of just
young people at the time who you guys
were friends with made it to the goal
who nuts at one point or another so I
add the at the specific request of Sam
Mac I won't play too much of this
because he's embarrassed by it but but
we will see sound like playing the
trombone in this video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so without further ado I would like to
invite our panelists to take the stage
[Applause]
thanks for all of your effort it's an
amazing event it's I think I'll be done
by now Ethan it's really amazing that
we're all here it's a pleasure for me to
talk to one of my favorite human beings
before musicians and I call these guys
that I think the geniuses of music of
this you know genre that we are and I
really mean it and we'll learn why I
think through this talk for nonny for
Iranian I think there is no need to
introduce salary Sahab 127 and there's a
non Jew of course but for non-iranian I
try to walk through the experience that
they have and I want to start this video
because I think it's a very good anchor
to go a little past that and a little
future of that and I don't know why
they're embarrassed by that because I'd
love them but it's a very good time if
you guys want to deny it so I think
that's a good time because everything
there was no venue there was no nothing
and I think I don't know about Mohsen
Namjoo but I talked to salmon that they
even didn't know that this thing is
gonna go and become something that it is
today right well yes coming we didn't
know we were a band we were a bunch of
kids playing music and making music and
then at some point there was this record
store in Tehran
Beethoven bought back in time and Iran
is twice and he told us that there's
this underground online music
competition
we should apply for this and you're like
all right so what do we do
there's like alright there's a music
studio here's the address go record a
song apply for this and that are like
okay so when they're we recorded a song
it was really difficult for us to record
as we didn't know how to and we
submitted it to Baba and I was like
what's your name but we don't have a
name we didn't even think of
so we basically picked the first random
thing that can you do my random
generator
no you're just walking down the street
and we saw like a car you know number
just like a 127 sounds good I mean I
have the same experience about our
band's name because we we were we were
in the car like driving yeah like we
were we were going to University of
sherry yeah and we were like we don't
have a name how we should introduce her
so then it was a time that I think there
were a lot of bands with like names that
were going back to our history aspect
and I was like let's pick a name that is
very very purely Persian and we used gas
patch which is the four letters that
exists in Farsi and doesn't exist in
Arabic and that was it that's that that
was the name that we pitched and Mohsen
Namjoo how did you come up with your
band name
okay can I have this piece of movie for
myself no my background was different
because I studied the traditional music
traditional way of singing at the age of
12 and 13 and then after going to the
University for music and then not the
finishing the school and then with the
living for some years in confusion the
guy with the with the
I was writing and making my own music
then you can call it still now like like
world music was based on the traditional
Iranian scales but the guy happy with
the long hair and the with the yellow
Gator he organized everything he
gathered us he did all those things he
would he was a kind of a really special
guy because that time in nineteen eight
in Mashhad Mashhad is the most important
religious city in Iran and you're like
like beside one of the prophets grants
on his birthday and that's very
important you should be like wow and
there but he knew jethro tull camels
Supertramp and all of this music he was
a great collector and he was copying
those cities and he was making money
based on that and good guitar player
electric guitar player and the bass is
there I had no I was telling to stomach
right now he still doesn't know how to
read the music how to read the notation
and he and the most of them that was
just everything came up from the
ignorance actually and maybe and when
like a kid as sad mag mentioned when
when your kid you you have no idea of a
falling-down that's why you can easily
walk on the border on a blade I like
like high wall but when you're mad short
you you're more getting more
conservative and and like being scared
of many things like maybe we are now but
that time we had no idea what we were
doing and and the name band Abdi choose
that for mod out of muddy waters like
mod mu D and mod band and also mod is
the first Kingdom Persian Kingdom
Persian Empire in
before revolution that Iranians are so
grateful of that and the but after that
yeah with we did that kind of rock I
continued with my own style and also I I
wrote some rock songs inspired by this
band but we were separated then are
these in London now and the rest of the
band are in Iran so I think if you guys
know sorry but you notice that and in
this house you really get a vibe of 70s
right it's it's very interesting kids
like the fashion and music kinda stopped
coming from West to Iran after 1979 kind
of stuff there like that there was
videos there perfect example of that so
that was like yeah it's it's really 7
easy because we have to do this math the
sideburn yes but I could it was really
did the 70s that we were experiencing
and liberally because our calendars are
different that was I think 70 maybe 3 or
so what year is that I mean 9 2001 okay
which is what mad which is what I mean
like you know in our calendar ah what do
we need actually think that it's better
to use those numbers because if I tell
you our calendar
[Laughter]
okay 70s at 82 so it's it's art ages so
I'm gonna also like go go to the moment
that I met these guys they don't
remember me because I was not a musician
I'm still not a musician and so for me
was going and seeing this guy so I think
I met you I don't know if you remember
at floors house in South oval there was
a there was a you see like he came so
we're talking about there is a lot of
memories that we really lost because we
are all guilty of death there's parties
and music and all the water bottles that
I had in many in any recording is
actually not water follow it so vodka
yeah so yeah so I met him over there and
I met you and really like in the
beginning just like play music so our
band was a little different because
Sardar and I were both studying music at
a time mm-hmm and Sora was writing
lyrics and coming up with the melodies
for his songs and we were getting
together at Sadler's place to just
simply practice our music and it was a
little so so Rob was not yet with you
guys or he was under Italy using here
yeah he started to ban basically he and
Ali the bass
we're in the video they started a band
they basically got introduced to each
other way this guitar player and they
headed for you and then later on Saurabh
and I only decided that they don't like
that guitar player so they started
playing together just as a duo and then
Sadler was a mutual friend he started
playing piano in that Sava and I had
this jazz duo band which was you know
like we playing basic standard jazz
stuff and then I joined a band mm-hmm
had four songs at the time I played
trombone for three songs so then I was
in the band and yeah everything is
started basically from the first
underground music I'm gonna get yeah
because I still want to go a little
before that and then V so so I think
before age wise I think there are a
couple of other people that were playing
music just in parties and by parties I
mean man that that concept and it was no
man Jovi pure man yeah and this is even
before our eyes between and it's all
about covering Hotel California all the
time you would go to any man I think
there is like two guys that play
California and that was for a long time
that was going on I think until Arash
betwee and his band and I think later
ball yeah they started bringing Farsi to
the western style of I think I don't
know if you want to call it fusion or
underground rock I still have you know
like a lot of debate with my friends
that we have our own style we don't want
to really name it any of these things
but so I think Farsi was a game to this
movement in Iran
and in the beginning I called the
Iranian rock Hafez Sagna rock because it
was all you know western music and some
was just reading and [ __ ] are at some
some of the Hoffa study and I think the
nature of it was that because he thought
that this is the only way that he can
I'm talking something that I'm not sure
but I thought that he was thinking that
he can get approval for something
that if it's office anxiety until I
think the first time that I listen to
Mohsen Namjoo it clicked that oh it is
really possible to use Farsi the way
that he used and I think all of us were
newbies by that so I want to talk about
thinking but before before saying that
definitely later you're gonna talk about
that first of all to Tara never
irreversible Solomon was Billa and then
we talked about in details but before
talking about myself I was gonna mention
something about the 127th time because
the as I mentioned Abdi had no idea
about the notations our bassist player
was not actually that was like based on
the like like their pure instinct and
just just playing music but this bad
conceptually because right now I'm I'm
working on a book hopefully one year two
years later is gonna be finished about
that from my point of view writing about
the history of underground music in the
independent music in Iran and this band
without any exaggeration that because
Salma can I we haven't met each other
for two years and because the bureau we
both are busy in New York mercy
teammates but here was the first first
opportunity to see each other they were
read music they were knowledgeable Samak
has absolute error you know you know
absolute error like like yeah like like
when when you're gonna just sing that to
256 or 440 about the exact Hertz exact
frequency he can and also sad sad or
right now he is organizing the the core
of the music scene alternative music
scene in in Tehran right now Sagar is
running many many bands like palettes
like bomb Ronnie like already is a very
good counselor about that and also so
Rob the the sea
was not a musician and maybe it was not
that was not that good singer but singer
but this is but this failure I think
that's a part of a speciality of of that
back because is is like like my playing
sitar is definitely comparing with the
set of players and nobody there but with
the jessica's sharing those ideas of
sitar to just playing sitar like playing
I don't know tangent dream with Satori
is going to be something else and
something not not very special good or
bad and but soul robbed their singer was
coming from the family intellectual
family his mom is a really very
creditable translator of mythology in in
Iran also she is one of the first niches
translators to to Farsi language I mean
this band that I this is this is my idea
about them without considering our
friendship because the this band was the
conceptually was the most intellectual
band in underground music in our
generation and because they accept
having the knowledge of music they were
looking for the idea of that smart idea
of mixing to just having mixing
something with something that is really
mmm really new and special to just say
because the time 2001 1382 for you we
were serving
we were starting this underground music
and then everyone everybody knew each
other why that festival that the human
is going to talk about and the main
stream was like Islamic pop music was
announced everywhere in official TV and
Islamic pop music means having electric
guitar and drums and with just
delivering the idea of Shia and talking
about them it like the Muhammad's
daughter has a desire to just they're
talking about that or having some
suggestions some orders to the society
to just oh please they put your garbage
at the 9 p.m. out of the door you know
the rock music rock music conceptually
was not rock music but just having the
instruments of rocks but this kind of
bands she asked also was was not was not
in like well known everywhere but in my
generation many of those bands and
unfortunately many of them they moved
out from Iran or they're not active
anymore and then the music scene is
something else now that we're going to
talk about the next session but that was
my short explanation with my English
that oh sorry we're what they want to
insert part about the idea that you said
about the hobby Hafiz and Persian
heritage of literature with contemporary
music I was coming from the from the
tradition from the some roots of folk
music Iranian folk music and also
traditional music and for me with two
three elements now not on that age
because that age was absolutely in
ignorance but after just looking back I
can say this I can have this
interpretation of myself that
first of all Lauren's as we saw here was
not was not a way of expression
expressing something specific like I'm
singer I'm just singer this is Lauren
this is just instrument
I'm not pop singer and I don't care
about this style
I'm not traditional singer I'm just
general singer and they're just like
like a sound producer sound maker you
know with having this general idea also
Hafiz Rumi and all those pets were not
being to just the movie or contemporary
music today some centuries earlier than
us to just sitting beside those
maestro's to just having respect for
them and delivering their message to us
because the error is absolutely
different than rock music the the
expression of rock music is something
else and Rumi is something else that's
why I was thinking now I'm saying that
maybe I was thinking of having the
general idea of sounds - just thinking
of some elements rhythm for example Rumi
and office of full of rhythms language
we have Persian language english
language scales we have half Tosca and
the Iranian traditional scales and at
the other side blues and a major minor
and their mixture and also pentatonic
scale and the style of singing we
considering all of this I was thinking
of just thinking of general idea of
mixing and with having with with keeping
the respect for Rumi ask him to please
myself come with us come to our age
please put this
headset tune your air and run with us
let's go to the park
let's just let's let's let's let's
having with conversation contemporary
conversation with each other that's why
maybe if would be any point of
interesting thing in in as you saying
about the having Hafez and drew me in my
first song for true rock music the idea
was coming out of this too just not
placing anything specific in its place
but you took it to the next level your
your songs were maybe half from Sri
Madhavi office but then you had a lot of
new songs that was not part of what the
lyrics was by myself a conversation with
okay yeah this is basically what I real
over that so basically how I know about
Mohsen I learn about most I was Saurabh
map data from Tehran Avenue one day
can't you see I was like listen there is
this CD it's this guy his name is Mohsen
Namjoo you go listen to it but don't
give it to anyone he's very sensitive he
doesn't want anyone to know and we took
the CD and then it was almost as
original songs and not through mere
savvy and I personally was blown away by
it because it was the first time that
anyone in Iran at this person that I
heard that figured it out wrote the
lyrics and performed it because that the
concept of being a singer-songwriter
didn't really exist before them like all
the music before the Revolution in Iran
was a full-on production you know you
had a singer you had a band you had a
marriage
you had someone who would write de
luring specifically for the singular the
whole idea of someone playing the music
and having his or her original works
with it didn't really exist and then
when I first heard one saying oh my god
this guy really figured it out and I
think you want to talk about Saurabh
Isabella liked him because he always
like moved from English so yeah that was
our first two records were yeah and it
was probably because we couldn't really
write anything in Farsi that we liked so
you know he was influenced by mostly no
he was taking his own path I mean he's
way of different two ways yeah even I
mean the fact that we were all scared of
bringing that type of I think Farsi that
we couldn't control it in in the nuances
and and the rhythms of English it was
hard and I I mean if you listen to their
back there are a lot of not a lot of
them but the proportion of them he was
really just reading you know like so
it's basically the idea of rabbits happy
right don't know how to back at a
Bewley's but okay yeah thank you so it
was the idea of back at Evelyn he was
reading a lot of that w at the time in
early and that guy on Medina's I became
the president and he was really pissing
us it's very unpleasant to see and we
never wanted to be directly you know
saying anything about anything but
badenside it seemed like a medium that
you could you know talk about stuff and
make fun of us stuff cause like that's
the whole thing you know there's a humor
to it and cutting star enemies is like
kind of more important than we say and
the message yes exactly so like that and
it's just like that's an album all
mostly in 6/8 and it's like very happy
mm-hmm but definitely was one of the
most depressed time of 127 or like oh my
god this guy now
we can fly anywhere anymore and it goes
like when we came to president like all
the music venues venues right it shut
down in all the little places that we
could play I was like that guy Jeff at-5
suddenly it was this guy who was running
for army Hall in Tehran mark university
then he got fired and he kind of liked
us he thought we had good kids so he
would let us play once a year like he
got fired so we couldn't do that anymore
like a bunch of the other places tatted
on it got closed then I just like his
music school basically I said that we
had this house era yeah it was parties
in houses then they had a short time of
studio that people would go to studios
bring their friend and they were playing
and then we got to the venue where I
think it really was a short life but I
myself thought that okay the room the
Iranian young generation revolution has
a start yeah we thought we're getting
there
we're getting it because there was a
time that we I think it's after Tehran
Avenue and we're gonna really focus on
that right now
but I was talking to sound like if he
remembers that but after you know those
competitions
Yasu Sufi came and said UNICEF is
putting money for doing an outdoor rock
festival and we went there each of these
bands were invited for two days like two
days we're getting that believe it or
just like this is definitely a trap
there wasn't gonna kill us here it's
gonna be like around here or something's
happening some things like is helping us
UNICEF to move from here and obviously
got canceled and like four hours before
getting ready I mean maybe you guys knew
about it more because we were not in
contact with them and we were like
getting ready like putting the drums and
stuff and we got the coroner's that
there was a you know waterfall we love
that part and we were going there that
you yes you told us this is canceled
right so I think that era was very short
bi pulled out a hot cat so like it was a
show getting canceled was a regular
thing back then like the first time on
Avenue thing it was a you can start
talking about it yeah the first time say
it was basically the story that I told
him Bob back to all those who submit
music and a lot of band is how many been
submitted music for that one like maybe
20 the first one year I was one like
Morden no more than 20 minutes 20
minutes but the second that the first
year was your band 127 second year was
at the French song and also I did my own
senior it was kind of a B bands and
there was lots huge amount like was more
than 200 300 and then everyone figured
out how the do is underground music here
yeah there was this show that we had and
[Music]
nobody nobody knew that being a band is
a thing you could be a band you know
it's like we didn't certainly know that
and by the third times a lot of younger
people needed absorb it so that's
something we can't have a band it's not
something that we just left and you know
hockey or our parents traditional tapes
definitely your dad smart to - I don't
know that you can you can share your
idea about this that you know from the
Western point of view from the research
view we can see those innocent musicians
in Iranian Islamic Republic and under
the limitation under the censorship we
were doing we were doing hard things and
we had a really hard time definitely it
was true but for us honestly for myself
for our bad for my friends for anyone
that festivals
was not that we are doing something
revolutionary
well because we should just be be be
careful that not spiritualizing the idea
of that we were we were like fighting
with the censorship worried we were just
having fun
nobody was fighting but there from them
like a some like it yeah outside of Iran
when we see definite theater is how we
can animate the Islamic Republic as a
the worst regime about the art which is
right and also and armies our musicians
are very like like very innocent and
very very like full talented musicians
that are all of them there understand
censorship and if they were out of this
censorship they were going to be a
Mozart Bach or Beethoven or something no
it's not true that's a we were all so
that's why we don't remember some of
those calendars because we were walking
on the sky many times and they were just
very wrong we were having fun we like
and there but mmm
now is we can look back to that history
and honestly be be proud of some point
of that - just okay we had no idea that
we were doing these things and for
example that I'd be better off a friend
of mine was saying because - ice
definitely you had this experience twice
on a stage they closed our concerts
where we were playing again didn't like
him okay give me the mic and go and it
was like this and you know that kind of
that kind of pain that kind of pressure
and the developer was saying I really
need the Roger Waters to be here to see
you see if
he is more painful or asked to just have
it because he was you know he always was
complaining about the limitations of the
British society yeah yeah his his
problem was with Margaret Thatcher but
but that was that was a true story and
happened to any any one of us I think
just I'm always try to keep it in my my
own mind to just to keep this balance
not exaggerating of our experience and
not that like humiliating that so I
wanted to actually talk a little short
about this politicization of our you
know time and era and I shared my
experience because as I said I was doing
something completely irrelevant to music
and then suddenly I become a singer
because I was trying to mimic you I
think and but but I was doing like 10
years of you know my own science in IPM
and institute of physics and mathematics
and no one asked me what you're doing so
I got there speak like microphone the
first time and I started saying singing
then like in two weeks you renews BBC
after everyone was around us and in the
beginning we were like sort of like
again before them was just their jobs
they were just having a pathology was
not just like really they're caring
about us that was like okay we have this
oh this few your nice young generation
that oh you know blues yeah that's what
I wanted to say that was ambulance but
everyone in Iran all the musician wrong
musicians not definitely it is most one
is but many of them different oh it's
coming let's talk about back then really
thought that that's exposure for us as a
band and he's got a great you know
people gonna hear us
but first experience design yeah but he
went too much because that yeah I
remember that there was a time right
before the election
Ahmadinejad they're like all these
career reporters with this one
translator and he he was the guy who's
guiding artists reporters around they
would go and interview Hashem you'd have
sent journey and then we go interview
nomination they would comfortable from
now we're really happy about it but as
you know I do it professionally right
now as a musician never get exposure for
your band or your music in a news
channel right you know we were waiting
on Europe used to show us you know it's
like we didn't know it back then but
they used us I was like yeah there's
just you know election going on and
these are these guys and also they play
music in you on so that's the point we
are I am the Coco the gorilla and
they're showing that oh we can talk of
course because we have the 60s of you
know Persian jazz music that now I when
I look back to that I don't know if you
guys heard the --racks --racks --racks
right right that's great and you know
like we had that we passed that be just
forgot and it was in our genes somehow
that it came back so yeah I just wanted
to just of the business work for that
you know like non-iranians the way that
this happened to us first was nice but
then at least me I I felt really bad
that we're like that monkey in a cage
that they're showing that oh we can also
do this exact so yeah so listen I don't
know that the underground music on that
time I think was a luxury problem of the
I think we had many many priorities we
have many many like most important
problem in Iran based on that about the
poverty and the no one from the after
from ZDF although they were like I
didn't see that just like they're giving
they putting their or making the
reportage about the poor people in
Tehran like and there was a just think
that caring about some like exactly yeah
okay what is your problem but but my
problem was not a priority because I was
just having fun with my own job and
but okay everything is is fashion and
definitely at that time was that kind of
no I mean I want to finish it by a
little focusing on each of them if
you've got you know minutes okay yeah so
because he talked you talked about how
it's not to be staff was great in their
music and I want to just say when I
listen to orange I know it's not like
you that's it but I was always wondering
that what is this man because the band
sounded great right so very original
yeah it was very original and none of us
know about those guys I think I want to
I wanted to just like in a minute tell
us that how you get to those people
because that was not anymore
yeah they have I had this opportunity
with a very low budget to record some of
my songs in his studio in Tehran after
finishing the military service and also
having those on Sox's unsuccessful
concerts with the with a body and the
banner I moved back to Tehran and then
then they stood you asked me to record
another album and then I asked those
guys to come play with action and that
was that was permitted because most of
lyrics was from the Persian classical
music classical poets like from Rumi
office and at Turin so and I want to
finish this with you because I think
he's going to talk about the present of
mute that he's like the what's happening
in Iran right now but so when I said
he's a musician that's a genius I think
I want to just mention that like three
years ago when I was talking to him
because he picked up an instrument that
was not very like no one was really like
you know my parents are both musicians
and when I was a little kid I was
playing pianos because everyone thinks
of the you kids should play piano I
[ __ ]
I'm sorry you know if it sounds like
sitting in an office desk right and I
went to the Teheran conservatory when I
was 12 and everyone thought that you
know I was gonna play piano but then I
saw this kid with a loud shiny horn
walking was like that I want that and
that was the only instrument we didn't
have at home and I want to say that
mentalists also is very like humble to
saying that but exact sound like is
instrumentalist an instrument that was
not that popular in Iran and he got to a
point that when he came here fully glass
got him to play you told me that you
were just playing Adi for him that's it
that's not music but his D was so
perfect that he picked this guy among a
lot of other it's really funny like so
traditionally symphonic orchestra has
three trombones safron symphonic
orchestra had two trombones and when it
was 18 still in conservatory they came I
was like dude should come and play if an
orchestra and so basically ruin my
education because I never went to school
every day
it took me seven years to get my
bachelor's the thought of music is I was
like all the professors were my
colleagues during the day and my mom
really had a hard time I remember just
like trying to pick me two schools like
kid you gotta go study I was but even
now he is again like the humble that he
was talking about after trombone he
moved to something new that he's a
producer right now and magnetic
and he's recording and you know like
doing live music with very very amazing
bands I learned about I got lucky I
don't play it cool or anything they're
the first Iranian band not a specific
underground or over and they to play
that they played in South by Southwest
me an agent says there before
just open the panel to the people I was
just say add something about your
question about orange and how physics
sadly and roomy
that's a another idea that I prefer that
that time is owning their concept of the
roomie for your music that's why that
make it contemporary if Rumi is talking
to his own beloved you can just have
your own interpretation of that and then
make it contemporary with with your own
maybe if if something was sound sounding
different to some of the audience there
maybe that's what one of the reasons to
just having for example in Seoul I had
these examples many this example many
times when a traditional single Iranian
singer they sings oh is just a Hafez is
there and each line of Hafez is talking
about something or maybe it's two lines
of talking about something but the
singer from the beginning to the end as
himself mr. X mr. why he is like he is
sitting there and he is singing Hoffa's
but I was kind of trying to be to be an
actor - just - just characterize all of
those lines and then the first line
behalf of a young man second line behalf
of another person third line fourth line
that's why
these are all just experience and
definitely you can definitely you can't
generalize them and having this like as
a rule to just deliver to make things
complicated but it was that song where
you really perform each of those lines
the old man all right like
if you want to write another comment and
so you know there's this is obviously
I'm totally appreciate all the
sentiments expressed by all three of you
of a Hydra young and you are having good
time and you know that and this
resistance toward being framed as the
tortured sort of young Iranian under
repression under the Islamic Republic
and all of that totally appreciate that
but I think that resistance to that has
also led to some I spoke to Sanok and
yeah it was hard to feel like you were
putting your soul and blood and
everything you know so much no it's like
I mean was not very conscious like most
of that from for us was not bit idea of
revolution was just unconsciously doing
that with the passion of music just just
doing doing doing many times going
upstairs to that ministry get permission
but that's funny
after Ahmadinejad because Ministry of
Culture to get permission to us to
publish our albums that was the only way
to be someone to be
to be somebody and be up there and then
yeah but after I met in the shot
yeah it was like it like a dad like like
a father you know that the the river
sauce and they were just play mother
please give us permission to just be be
out there but that that was absolutely
crazy and out of mind
and that's why the real underground
music came up after that everyone with
having software home studios they didn't
care about the Ministry of Culture
they've published their own music wire
Internet and when I look and just throws
us I see that there must be some context
for the kind of music that you produce a
cultural production that you have a
market as well how do you think
follow-up behaves for money and this is
the outcome of any very torturous
difficult social environments mode of
music and gave it such
honest or do you think that regardless
of the political circumstances and the
presence of her release estate they
envisioned you had there was and there
was a reception for your music out there
because of the generational changed
because in which of these you think of
these two factors that actually
differentiate them were most significant
and of course there is a second part one
question is that the fact that you're
all here rather than being in Iran what
does that say does it say that in a
sense that authoritarian regime
pre-build production or do you think
this this is an ongoing thing regardless
of your presence or absence so the first
part of your question I think that
having the stomach Republic of Iran as a
regime that it is is the reason that the
music that we all play in Iran is like
that and it's like you know music has
value in Iran just because of the
stomach Republic if I you know cuz like
in modern countries like the u.s. music
totally lost value music is a lifestyle
now there is no such a thing as a music
with a message or music that just like
would trigger the audience there's no
such thing as that it's been gone since
the 70s and the 80s you know like after
Vietnam bar and like all of that there's
no music that actually does that Iran
because of the Slovak Republic there is
still music music has values you know
and all of that but um and I don't know
if Iran was like you know speaking of
Africa free country we would still play
or at least say that kind of stuff you
know
lyric wise or even people with you know
give us the attention that they did
under the circumstances under notable
leaving I think wherever you leave for
25 years is enough you can go somewhere
else
Iran certainly is not the most pleasant
place to live at least for someone like
you know us to live there
I lost everyone you know it's just just
we were touring around when we lived in
Tehran with Saturday's 1/2 for like four
years in a row we were just like go do
shows in the u.s. in Europe everywhere
you can come back to Tehran cuz like
that was home but then it get to the
point that it wasn't home you know just
because of an medina said you know I
don't have any political than I judge me
but because of that guy you know it just
got much more unpleasant to live I
remember when he became the president
the night before I was walking in van AK
and it smelled like dirty socks you know
all of those Betsy Gees were house like
a holy [ __ ] this guy's gonna get
president you know he's gonna just gonna
get elected tomorrow and he did and
since that you know it was very
unpleasant to living it wrong I think
you guys will be also a little and it's
like this is happening right now cuz
they came to their I see more of bands
that are like every show that you go to
bands that are not political they come
up on this stage and say something about
the carnot situation or Trump or about a
specific thing like NRDC or a human
whatever and now like we're getting to
the point that people are talking about
political stuff that they didn't for the
last eight years cuz like you know
everyone was super friends with the
administration because they were nice
but yeah but Iran was that basically so
I don't know if it wasn't the Islamic
Republic we would do this still or like
the way that we did it were not I mean
at least has read
one book in this oh yeah this guy but
but regarding your that the second part
of your question professor I think
that's a good related to our next
session because about talking about the
t+ sizing the music I think that's
that's that's a very good question that
why you're here and because after get
getting rid of us they they really know
the game now that rock music that they
had a problem with back then in
iran-related it's now it's all legal
they played that kind of music in the
radio all the bands have you know
because there's one one simple reason
because that music is not the mainstream
music in the West anymore
I think hip hop is the new thing for
Iran that is just you know big band is
like yeah I was telling Solomon
yesterday that we now we still we even
have Islamic rap to just supporting the
very fundamentalist Islamic ideas with
rap music that's why they they for
example they pushed away the pushed the
side of Easter half to be but they're
making fakes at the mister half inside
the time that's that's another story
that we talked about it next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]